hi guys it's me again yag man i only
have a really shitty light on my phone
not all of us can be millionaires and
afford lamps anyway I found this really
cool game that I just wanted to share
with you all yeah i'll put the link of
the description and you can play it it's
game based on your reactions and music
I'm really really bad at reaction games
so yeah we'll see how we go to lowes I
don't tell you its service here it's all
oh no
Oh
pretty much is this is real and you were
just walking through all this flashy
late use jump duck
gonna be this amazing song tools I don't
do these slides here
please
don't leave in five minutes
oh ok needless sky
about the time to the song [ __ ] if I can
see that you can't reach it
oh [ __ ] hey that Jake bit
I told you I jinx it [ __ ] all the way
back here 101 Dalmatians try not to be
one of those people who get really angry
and games it's just icky look at you my
life hell too I don't leave home sites
here it's all right you know
I
cut
okay okay Nicholas what about the time
to the song
shuns camera
sad
it is
she said
sir
okay so i gave up which is getting so
annoying so yes I would love to see if
anyone can actually finish this thing if
you can do it please send me a link to
the video because I would love to see
the whole play with the whole music
because the music is awesome but you
kind of forget that after work because
you're just too frustrated with the game
so anyway have a nice thing see you
later
haha